όσι οκτόλεπτά των πουόσα για για ναγια να ευκολίνο ότη νίκη να διευκολίνο τη νίκ
είδαμε τον κόσμο να αρχετ χάμε περισσότερες συμετοχή προχθές και θεωρούμε ν θα έομε να
κόμα περισότερος με την κουρατια και βεβας για μας είναι μικρά θες τό πως θα
αντααποκριθούμε για των μεγάλον υβνα αυτό είνα τα γωνιστικών είναι το ένα και θεωρούμε ότι
στην μπορεία θα κεφάλλο εοποιηθεί με τω έρθουν περισσότερα παιδιά στο άθελμα της μεραθώς αυτό
είναι το το δεύτερο σημαντικων κάντηνάγωση μας είαι ότι ανοίξαμε την τεράστια συζήτη η μποέχεί
να κάμειμε των αθρετικών τούρισμο στων τόμο μας που το και τού των ένα μεγάλο
θέμα ένα μεγάλον κεφάλιών και βεβαίος στα λλα είναι τα οικονομικά οφέλη που έχει να
κάνει με τους εμμέσως και του άμεσους φόρους με την πληρότηταν των ξενοδοχίων με τους
ξένους επισκέπτες θα λειτουργήσει η εστείας ταξινοδοχία θα μάθουν την κύπρον όσοι θα έρθουν και
βεβαίως η κύπρος από το προηγούμενο παραθυρών έχει πει στο σστο χάηλατ των αθελητικώ εγονότων
παγκόσμια τους αγόνεσης σε θυνικής έχουν μεταδωθεί σε επαγκόσεις μια κλίμακα άρα έχει ξεκινήσει η
διαδικασία την οποία ν εμείς φανταζόμαστα ένα από τοκοσένανικό δι που μας είχαν πει και
άλλυφί άλλης συνεργάτες φίλι από όμως κονδίε ι οποιίες διοργάνω αν τοβρομάσκι θεωρείδι ότι κάποιοι
κεί τ στην ολί θα μας μίνει και μια κληρονομιά σύγχρονης αναβαθμισμένης κλιστείς αίθουσας η
οποίία ότι είναι πόμενη μέρα θα μπορέσει να να φιλοξενήσει αθιλητικά γεγονό τα παρόμιου και
ψηλότεριοπιβαιδού όχι μόνο καλαθόσφερα και βεβαίός και άλλα ιβαία τι τα οποία θα μπορεί και
σως να και αρχή για να α παπομιστούν και άλλναι αυτό έχουμε επείς στην αρχή
ναβεβαι τώρα θεωρίσε ότι κάποιο ππήγαν να πολιτικό ποιγήσουν αυτόν το ιγόνος νομίζωυ εναι μέσα
στην κουρτούρα μας και δεν μας ενοχλήγ αυτόν τ αυτό το θέμαεμείς θέλουμε να τους
καλέσουμε όλους να είναι συμπαραστάτες το έχο οποίο επανελιμένος δεν μπορει ομοσποντία με κανανένα λόγον
δεν θα μπορούσεν καν να διεκδικήσει